oh my god look at our christmas presents
from my mom
kim kardashian showed off these lavish
christmas gifts courtesy of mom kris
jenner i'm obsessed with all of the you
know holidays and decorating don't we
know it chris
as kim's instagram story proved the
kardashians matriarch was feeling extra
generous this year
oh my god look at our christmas presents
from my mom
yes for all of her kids
and the personalized golf carts didn't
leave anyone to guess who gets what
chloe and i got the pink ones
well this has to be courtney and travis
for sure it appears that golf might have
been the overall gift theme this year
remember when chris got everyone these
monogrammed golf clubs for easter
oh my gosh i just woke up on this easter
sunday and came into the kitchen and my
mom treats easter like it's christmas
you guys have no idea look what she got
all of us
oh my god you guys while expecting her
second child with travis scott kylie
jenner debuted her new kitten on
instagram over the weekend
[Music]
why don't we discuss
christmas eve oh there's much to discuss
about the kardashians christmas eve
party
i finally have a really good idea for
christmas kim shared these pics of her
little ones and if north and chicago
west's pink velvet looks seem familiar
fans pointed out they're clearly
channeling mom's snl monologue ensemble
and chris couldn't help but gush over
the festive looks
i'm a big presentation person on
kendall's picks from the night chris
wrote quote i mean
wow and when chloe and daughter true met
saint nick she said quote gorgeous girls
with santa
of course chris gave everyone a special
gift this year
let's take a listen dashing through the
snow
yep that's a snippet of chris singing
jingle bells which she shared to
instagram with some help from her
soon-to-be son-in-law as she explained
in the caption quote thank you travis
barker for the memory and fun and for
adding your magical drums and thank you
kourtney kardashian for your mesmerizing
jingle bells and there's maybe something
to look forward to in 2022 travis
pitched in the comments quote christmas
album next year dashing through the snow
on a one-horse open sleigh
or the fields we go
[Music]